voters looking to unseat President Trump
in 2020 not going to be happy with Mark
Cuban the billionaire saying the current
field of Democratic contenders don't
stand a chance
Cuban also not ruling out a presidential
run of his own as an independent watch
I've said it many times it would take
the perfect storm for me to do it so
there's there's some things that could
open the door but you know I'm not I'm
not projecting or predicting it right
now who do you think of the Democratic
side right now has the best chance
against President Trump nobody right now
if you look at the Democratic field it's
all politician and politicians are the
least trusted of every profession and so
you know it's just it's too early to
tell
Shannon he may be right I mean he's a
reality TV star and he's saying you need
somebody with that kind of profile to
defeat Donald Trump what do you think I
think of what he talks about this that
the Democrats have shades of Ross Perot
like a total freak out time
just like when Howard Schultz talks
about it or any of these other
independent people that actually have
name recognition they've got money
they've got connections they have the ID
and they could move forward when you
think about how Ross Perot changed the
trajectory of Bush 41 not having a
second term I think someone like Mark
Cuban makes the Democrats very nervous
because what he brings to the table more
so than Schultz even yeah because I
think he's he's done whole reality TV
thing I think he's you know he's mixed
it up with Trump before I could see them
going toe-to-toe and both of them really
enjoying it so Jesse you're a guy who
gets down to the basics I see this
campaign as Mark Cuban saying hey that's
a fake billionaire I'm a real
billionaire vote for me yeah when I
teased him about it to his face I said
you're just jealous that another
billionaire celebrity ran for president
and won and he goes I'm not jealous
Trump's not a billionaire and then I
told them that we were doing the segment
today and he said tell Greg I'll have
the Cramps play at the inauguration ah
got my vote
he's a cramps fan and I like him I'm not
a Mavericks fan they're not doing too
well but I like him that he speaks his
mind and the only thing is I think this
he's just floating this run out there
because he's trying to boost his brand a
little bit and get his name in the news
but if you think about if he does run
who does he take votes away from so I
ran his platform positions through the
matrix and we found that he's like a
taller better-looking Mike Bloomberg
with a hint of libertarian Ron Paul and
a splash of ACLU so bottom line he's not
going to run so it doesn't matter but he
did say something else interesting so
far the democrat proposals have been all
headline porn that's a great don't think
they believe what they're proposing is
passable and it's true if you think
about the gun grabbing the socialized
medicine the green New Deal that's never
gonna get passed they even put the green
New Deal up to a vote in the Senate and
every single Democrat abstained yeah so
Dana he did say that nice things about
Joe Biden he said Biden is a smart guy
and he could do a good job he just
doesn't think he has the possess so he
uses a word charisma and you know we
listen to there's 24 candidates now and
you listen to a lot of their sound bites
and who grabs the ear right if you think
about it if you're in the r8 if you're
in the car you're not not everybody's
glued to their television although thank
you for watching I mean for five bucks
if you think about it's the charisma
whoo-hoo-hoo makes you want to listen
yeah and if you listen to Mark Cuban
like he calls it doesn't even have to be
in the studio he's like Trump right he
calls in you know Howard Schultz that
can't call in right that's not gonna
happen for him and in fact I just don't
know where he is right now yeah when
you're hot they take you on the phone
yeah that's the rule I think I first
started there was somebody who called
into this show that was not it was not
Bill O'Reilly Bill O'Reilly
okay so what wouldn't human saying is
what we've been saying here for the last
couple of months what's missing is the
electrifying non-politician the funny
unpredictable person who shuns all of
the political platitudes who doesn't
talk like a politician the Democrats
don't have their Trump and the thing is
instead they have this I guess a 22
headed I don't know
24 added 24 headed jack-in-the-box and
they all look the same in the old days
we would say wow this is an impressive
field look at all these people but
because of 2016 now we go there's just
way too many I don't know who they are
it's this a big bus load of Talking
Heads I don't get it
the weird thing is is like you know that
used to be good now what's good is to
have somebody who's not a pollution
politician who's loud who doesn't sound
like a politician when you look at Biden
that's all you see his politician and it
feels like when he's talking and
watching the guy on crutches making its
way down a staircase at any moment it's
gonna collapse and be ugly whereas you
have somebody like Trump who could talk
for four hours about slippery stages and
I my point is this do the Democrats go
for the comfortable sweater in Biden who
feels like something you're used to or
do you go for that you know the the the
jumpsuit that Evel Knievel wears when he
went into this no gripper Canyon I think
they should get the Snake River when you
have a moment it's typically politics
runs and cycles and I think after Trump
there may be a desire for some sweaters
and stability we're stable politicians
Wan are every bit as dangerous as
anybody else they start wars they do
stupid things we have an unpredictable
president who might be the most peaceful
president we've had any because he
doesn't want any one some people call
them a very stable genius
[Laughter]
[Music]
I will say they're both reality stars I
guess that's the moment in American Pie
it's all about being a reality TV and
maybe Snooki's gonna run they've all
said they want a woman on the ticket
here's your number - or - Ian I'm gonna
run as a Republican